as a company that specializes in big  data analysis and integration it has  always been our passion to make  bioinformatics more accessible to close  the data science gap for non-engineers  we have to focus on all of the central  issues that will enable anyone to be  effective at managing processing  analyzing and integrating large data  that is why today we are launching the  omics logic code playground  here we will be posting practical coding  assignments that will help you  understand the r and python code syntax  for common types of tasks a  bioinformatician faces in day-to-day  work  as a result you will learn how to  process genomic transcriptomic and  metagenomic data on the cloud or  dedicated high performance computing  server stack by launching processing  pipelines that structure and prepare  data for downstream analysis the